en alberta les chevaux sauvages font
partie du paysage depuis des centaines
d'années mais comme ils se nourrissent
parfois sur les mêmes terres que le
bétail certains éleveurs de bovins
souhaiterait voir un meilleur contrôle
de ses populations via la capture et
l'abattage une solution qui ne fait pas
l'unanimité
[Musique]
la région des piémonts dans le sud ouest
de l'alberta
c'est ici que la forêt boréale rejoint
les escarpements des rocheuses où les
rivières alimentés par la fonte des
glaciers coule vers les prairies
intérêts accidenté difficile d'accès où
la faune est aussi variés que les jeux
de lumière sur les pics enneigés des
montagnes
[Musique]
on les retrouve aussi bonnes espèces
animales qui évoque l'imaginaire mais
qui suscite la controverse
des centaines de chevaux sauvages vivent
ici depuis des générations
c'est un environnement confortable pour
eux il ya des criques rempli d'eau et
toutes ces collines où les rebonds sont
heureux ici
a séjourné à sillonner les secteurs les
plus reculés des piémonts
[Musique]
nous allons dans cette zone
c'est là qu'on trouve la plus grande
concentration de chevaux en alberta il y
en a probablement entre 700 et 1000 d'un
secteur anciens travailleurs de
l'industrie pétrolière
il s'investit aujourd'hui dans ce qui
est devenu sa passion
beau temps mauvais temps été comme hiver
il parcourt une région de 50 mille
hectares sur des sentiers de fortune
presque impraticable
[Musique]
tout ça dans l'espoir de capter quelques
précieuses images de chevaux sauvages
promis je publie les vidéos sur des
réseaux sociaux et ça devient chaque
fois guiral déjà en angleterre en
nouvelle-zélande en ouganda bref de
partout veulent voir des images de ses
chevaux en pleine nature
[Musique]
il suit leurs déplacements et ceux de
leurs prédateurs
[Musique]
ces caméras de vienne d'une fenêtre
privilégiée sur les écosystèmes des
piémonts rigaux parfois il réussit même
à s'approcher des chevaux
j'ai un lien très fort avec eux comme
s'ils me reconnaissais reconnaissez ma
voix
tous ces efforts ont un objectif bien
précis assurer la survie de ces animaux
je suis en train de recruter une
véritable armée de plus en plus de gens
connaissent l'existence de ces chevaux
et c'est là notre meilleur outil pour
persuader le gouvernement de laisser ses
bêtes vivre en paix
l'histoire de ces chevaux est
étroitement liée à celle du
développement de l'ouest canadien
[Musique]
ces animaux seraient en partie les
descendants des chevaux qui ont
contribué au développement des
industries forestières et minières au
tournant du xxème siècle durant la
grande dépression
des centaines voire des milliers de
chevaux auraient aussi été relâchés par
les fermiers incapable de les nourrir
les chevaux se sont adaptés au piémont
et leur nombre a grandi certains disent
que leur population aurait atteint les
200 mille bêtes dans les années 40 à
cette époque on les capture est permis
pour des envoyés sur les champs de
bataille en europe ou encore sur le
marché mondial de la viande chevaline
si bien que dans les années 80 il ne
restait plus qu environ 2000 chevaux
sauvages dans le sud ouest de l'alberta
pour in 600 souviens bien
il y a quelques années je voyais souvent
plus d'une centaine de chevaux dans ses
prix
éleveurs de bétail dans les piémonts il
connaît bien les chevaux sauvages et
leur impact sur l'écosystème de la
région
[Musique]
qui fait la plus grande différence c'est
que les chevaux habite cet environnement
12 mois par année alors que le bétail
passe beaucoup moins tant sur les terres
de la couronne
voilà donc l'enjeu de la contreverse les
bovins d'élevage et les chevaux sauvages
partagent les mêmes terres pour se
nourrir gardés dans des enclos jusqu'à
la fin du printemps les bovins sont
ensuite relâchés sur les terres de la
couronne pour paître en forêt or les
chevaux se nourrissent déjà dans ces
secteurs depuis la fonte des neiges
les années de sécheresse l'herbe ne
pousse plus ici la fétuque sabre une
graminée incroyable à haute valeur
nutritive qu'on retrouvait ici partout
autrefois a même complètement disparu
elle ne tolère pas le broutage du
printemps
ces chevaux ont aussi un impact sur les
élevages domestique
il arrive parfois que des étalons
sauvage saut par-dessus les clôtures et
s'accouplent avec nos jumeaux j'en ai
perdu quelques jeunes au fil des ans qui
se sont sauvés avec les troupeaux
sauvage
[Musique]
l'élevage de bovins est l'un des moteurs
économiques de l'alberta avec des
retombées de 14 milliards de dollars par
année
pour préserver cette industrie la
province accorde dans les années 90 est
permis pour la capture de chevaux
sauvages sur les terres de la couronne
des campagnes provincial de captures
sont aussi organisés
certains chevaux sont vendus à l'encan
d'autres se retrouvent dans des rodéos
mais surtout ils sont abattus et leur
viande exporté en quelques années la
population de chevaux sauvages chute
environ 1000 bêtes
mais au début des années 2000 tout
bascule
quelques chevaux sont abattues à bout
portant leurs carcasses mutilés
ou
les amateurs de chevaux comme pub en
dessous sont outrés
c'en était assez et on a été nombreux à
vouloir agir nous avons créé un gros
serveur burnside voir ces animaux huras
est magnifique ce faire capturer et être
envoyés à l'abattoir c'était intolérable
en 2014 le gouvernement de l'alberta
allons ce moratoire sur la capture de
chevaux sauvages
ils mandatent la world of the world
society pour trouver d'autres moyens
pour contrôler la population de chevaux
l'alberta veut éviter un scénario comme
celui qu'on retrouve au nevada où la
population de chevaux sauvages
s'approche des 50000
bob et son groupe se tourne d'abord vers
la contraception
il administre avec fusillé fléchettes un
contraceptif à une centaine de juin
mais le problème c'est qu'il faut
administrer une deuxième dose pour que
le produit fasse effet une tâche presque
impossible
c'était possible de retrouver les mêmes
troupeau il a fallu abandonner le
programme
il se tourne alors vers une autre option
sur ce terrain de 8 hectares enfouis
dans la forêt boréale se trouve un petit
ranch
c'est un centre d'adoption pour chevaux
sauvages
ces chevaux ont été capturés sur des
terrains privés et transportés ici
autrefois ces bêtes auraient été
destinés à l'abattoir ne
donner une deuxième chance à ces chevaux
et leur trouver un domicile permanent
c'est la solution idéale
parfois les chevaux arrivent ici de leur
propre gré c'est le cas de ces quatre
juments et de leur poulain qui rôdent
dans la forêt environnante
depuis quatre mois
bénévole au centre d'adoption cannes de
sketchup réussit enfin à s'approcher des
juments
on les a lentement habitués à notre
présence si bien qu'aujourd'hui ils
viennent manger directement dans so ont
bâti peu à peu une relation de confiance
avec
ses têtes jacques neko que revient la
délicate tâche de transformer ces
animaux sauvages en animaux domestiques
on lui apprend ne pas avoir peur quand
on touche dans la nature les chevaux
sont constamment sur le qui vive il doit
se battre sans relâche contre les
éléments et les prédateurs nous sommes
un de ces prédateurs est probablement un
des plus bizarres pour lui du fait qu'on
se tient sur deux pattes
que l'est
depuis quatre ans une centaine de
chevaux sauvages ont ainsi été
domestiqué est adopté
on fait on lit préfèrerait en liberté
mais c'est quand même bien meilleur sort
qu'auparavant
mais en dépit des succès du programme
d'adoption le gouvernement de l'alberta
n'a pas voulu renouveler le moratoire
sur la capture des chevaux en 2019
selon les chiffres de la province la
population de chevaux sauvages aurait
presque doublé depuis la fin des
captures organisé passant de près de 900
bas est en 2014 environ 1700 en 2019
costume gris good stuff sûrs
des chiffres contestés par ceux qui
passent leur journée sur le terrain à
suivre les troupeaux
[Musique]
le gouvernement estime le taux de
reproduction des chevaux sauvages entre
17 et 20% mais vous voyez ici je compte
de 35 à 40 chevaux et seulement cinq
poulets c'est peu et certaines
survivront pas l'hiver on n'a aucune
raison valable de chercher à réduire les
populations pour l'instant
un point de vue qui n'est pas du tout
partagé par bon nombre d'éleveurs dont
british
trouvant un équilibre je ne veux pas que
ces chevaux disparaissent ils sont là
depuis longtemps et ont le droit d'y
être mais refusé de faire une gestion
des populations suis contre
claude guéant
[Musique]
le droit qu'ont ces chevaux de vivre ici
est au coeur du débat aujourd'hui
s'agit-il comme le soutiennent les
autorités provinciales de descendants de
chevaux domestiques relâcher dans la
nature ou s'agit-il de populations
indigènes
les groupes de conservation sont
convaincus que c'est là que se cache la
clé de la protection de ces troupeaux à
long terme
ils font partie du paysage albertain
depuis beaucoup plus longtemps qu'une
vue l'admettre le gouvernement harper
pour madame marois trimestre
[Musique]
après la pause les chevaux sauvages en
alberta devrait-il être protégé
[Musique]
en 2019 il y avait selon les chiffres
officiels près de 1700 chevaux sauvages
dans les piémonts de l'alberta des
animaux qui ne sont pas protégées comme
le sont les espèces indigènes
les groupes de conservation veulent
convaincre le gouvernement de l'alberta
de la valeur patrimoniale et gêné de sic
de ces animaux afin d'en assurer la
survie
pour mieux comprendre l'origine de ces
chevaux le groupe de bob and soon s'est
associé à jos les poissons chercheur en
écologie de la faune à l'université de
calgary mes intérêts de recherche
principalement c'est sur le lien en
place vers c'est génétique la santé chez
espèces sauvages
depuis 15 ans il étudie les chevaux de
l'île de sable en nouvelle-écosse une
population sauvage unique au monde fait
un modèle pour étudier la santé animale
avenue naturel les chevaux de l'île de
sable sont protégés par canada c'est le
cheval excellent la nouvelle écosse
tandis qu'ici en alberta les chevaux
sauvages sont plutôt vu comme des
baisses donc ya pas de conservation n'y
a pas de recherche 11 - pas beaucoup de
recherches sur les chevaux il décide
alors de mettre son savoir à profit le
gouvernement les groupes de conservation
des chevaux ferait pas vraiment sur des
questions assez fondamental
[Musique]
certains soutiennent que ces chevaux
habitent les piémonts depuis des siècles
des populations établies bien avant
l'élevage de bovins
les groupes de conservation
suggère que ce serait plutôt les
descendants des chevaux introduit par
les espagnols dans les années 1500 dans
le sud des états unis qui aurait remonté
l'amérique avec les échanges entre les
peuples autochtones le non dit c'est que
si leur histoire est liée à l'histoire
amérindienne autochtone puis à la
création de l'alberta le développement
de l'alberta ailleurs plus une
justification de valeurs existent the
animals
pendant deux ans juste les poissons et
son équipe prélève des échantillons
d'adn des cheveux sauvages partout dans
le sud ouest de l'alberta il compare
ensuite ses codes génétiques aux
échantillons de race prélever un peu
partout sur la planète les résultats
sont étonnants il faut un bagage
génétique qui est un mélange de toutes
les les races de chevaux qui ont été
introduits en amérique du nord dans les
derniers 500 vont donc il ya les
espagnols peuvent être dues des chevaux
dans le sud des états unis mais aussi
les français qui ont être des chevaux en
louisiane puis en floride et andalouse
canada les anglais qui ont introduit des
chevaux il ya aussi les suédois qui
avait une colonne inalement reste des
états unis puis les néerlandais qui ont
aussi introduit des chevaux mais quand
on va dans le nord de l'alberta il ya
clairement des sous-populations de
chevaux qui sont d'origine des races de
chevaux de trait comme les percherons
donc l'origine est assez complexe
mais je dirai clairement une certaine
sous populations qui ont été ici
probablement depuis le début des années
1700 pour les chercheurs en écologie
animal la diversité génétique est un
atout important il ya beaucoup de
diversité génétique qui est en train de
disparaître parce que le peu d'intérêt
dans certaines races si on regarde les
chevaux de l'île de sable plus fous de
l'alberta et contribue clairement la
diversité génétique des chevaux au
canada mais aussi à l'échelle mondiale
non non ce n'est selon bob en deux
semaines ces résultats confirment ceux
qui soutient depuis vingt ans les
chevaux des piémonts doivent être
protégés au même titre que la faune
indigène
souhaiterait ce qu'ils soient désignés
comme espèces un statut particulier
admettez
d'autres soutiennent entre eux tant que
peu importe l'origine des chevaux ils
ont acquis le droit de vivre dans ces
contrées
ils sont ici depuis si longtemps qu'ils
ont bien droit d'y rester chaque jour
une vidéo à la fois la campagne de
sensibilisation de drogue lover dans les
réseaux sociaux prend de l'ampleur c'est
au puley encore aujourd'hui de nombreux
albertains ignore que ses chevaux existe
on s'est donné pour mission de changer
ça et de sensibiliser le plus de gens
possible
[Musique]
il lui arrive parfois alors qu'il
parcourt l'arrière-pays devenir lui-même
en aide à un cheval en détresse
comme ici en mai 2000 vingt lorsqu'il
est tombé sur une jument qui se noyait
dans un marais caché sous une couche de
glace
tout ce qu'on avait pour la sortir de là
c'était des sanguins au nassau mais nous
avons réussi
elle s'est éloignée s'est retournée
comme pour nous remercient puis il est
reparti nous on oui
[Musique]
mais parfois la nature suit son cours
inexorable
juillet 2019 une jument semble amener
son poulain en détresse vers le camion
de drogba le jeune animal vient
d'échapper aux griffes d'un loup
les blessures sont trop graves il n'y a
qu'une seule option le
poulain est abattu
le même soir le loup revient chercher sa
proie
on comprend que rien n'arrive pour y est
que tout fait partie du cycle de la vie
un équilibre naturel est déjà bien
établie
la classe des chevaux au sein de cet
écosystème frais justement l'objet des
prochaines recherches de l'équipe de
l'université de calgary c'est quoi les
effets directs et indirects des chevaux
sur les autres espèces de forniquer
comme le wapiti ou l'orignal c'est quoi
les impacts de développement du
territoire comme la foresterie sur les
populations c'est quoi les interactions
réel avec les bovins de la qualité des
pâturages ça va être important de
d'étudier ces questions là pour mieux
gérer notre territoire
février 2021 une équipe du ministère de
l'environnement de l'alberta survole les
piémonts pour compter les chevaux
sauvages
selon leurs repérages la population
aurait chuté de 20%
le gouvernement annonce alors la
création de comités dont le mandat sera
de se pencher sur diverses options de
gestion des chevaux sauvages et sur les
recherches portant sur la génétique de
ces animaux mais les autorités
n'écartent pas l'option de capture
organisées à l'avenir
[Musique]
ceux qui militent pour la protection de
ces troupeaux promettent de poursuivre
leur travail de sensibilisation afin
d'empêcher de nouvelles campagnes visant
à réduire les populations de chevaux
sauvages de la région
je pense que si ce genre de chose se
reproduise est la réaction du public
serait vraiment fort mal les gens sont
aujourd'hui guil plus conscients de la
valeur de ses chevaux
[Musique]